le vote va reprendre demain vers l'heure
du midi et les républicains semblent
toujours aussi divisées
oui tout à fait juste pour vous donner
une idée à quel point la Chambre des
Représentants est divisée même pour
ajourner ce vote à demain midi c'était
extrêmement serré c'est 216 élus étaient
en faveur 214 contre la majorité des
démocrates voulait que le vote continue
ce soir donc les républicains sont
toujours divisées on a aperçu qu'elle
veut de me confie sortir de la Chambre
des Représentants et dire qu'en fait il
y a du progrès mais qu'il n'est pas
convaincu d'avoir réussi à rallier ses
20 élus républicains qui persistent et
ne veulent toujours pas le soutenir je
vous propose d'écouter à ni lieu
républicain avec qui je me suis
entretenu un peu plus tôt Macron me call
qui lui dit écoutez ça fait partie de la
démocratie on va finir par s'entendre
Keven murative va finir par être élu
quel que soit le nombre de votes que ça
va prendre on l'écoute
[Musique]
mais en attendant l'impasse paralyse les
travaux du Congrès et sa préoccupe aussi
les démocrates
oui voilà il y a un délai vous savez que
tous les élus doivent être à samentés
ils ne le sont toujours pas donc ça crée
vraiment un malaise le président Joe
Biden a même dit aujourd'hui que c'était
embarrassant que l'image du Congrès en
est sali et puis Kevin il faut le dire
c'est quand même extrêmement humiliant
là on va avoir un septième vote
Madeleine demain midi et c'est possible
que les élus républicains qui ne votent
pas pour lui continueront à refuser de
voter pour lui vous savez il suffit que
quatre d'entre eux décident de ne pas
voter pour lui pour qu'il ne soit pas le
président de la Chambre des
Représentants ça prend 218 votes donc ce
n'est pas encore gagné et là je me suis
également entretenu avec une autre et du
républicaine qui me disait écoutait ces
personnes là sont en train de prendre le
parti en otage il y a quand même de la
colère on écoute
donc pour certains ces personnel donc ça
risque de ne pas changer alors déjà on
est en train de regarder qui pourrait
remplacer Kevin biographie mais pour le
moment tous les élus avec lesquels je me
suis entretenue m'ont dit non on est
avec avengrossi il a la majorité il a
85% du soutien des élus républicains
donc il faut qu'il gagne donc le
suspense perdure et à zéro on se redonne
rendez-vous demain je vous remercie
je vous en prie